Ultimately, behavior is about how
a device responds to these events.
To model this, we need to
understand what those events are.
For the next step in the state
chart modeling process,
we will look at how to determine,
for each of the external controls,
what stimuli or
events they can provide to the device.
Using the use cases we
have developed earlier,
why don't you begin to make a list of
the user actions that might generate
events that we would expect
the radio to respond to.
And as a hint, go back and
look at the picture, and
use it to find each of the ways
that user can affect its behavior.
>> Okay.
So,
the first is that the user can
switch the mode button, and
that's going to change our
state machine based on, we have
to look at what mode we're coming out of
to determine what mode we're going into?
>> So what is the event?
What is it that the user does?
>> It's just clicking
that little knob over.
>> So, sliding the thing?
And, there's really two events here.
There's one is pushing it to the right,
and one is pushing it to the left.
>> Okay.
>> Okay?
And, as a programmer,
if you were eventually
doing an implementation for
this thing, you would have
to deal with both of those.
And you want to deal with
them separately, right?
You have to know.
Now we could model those as two separate
events, or we could model them as one
event, maybe called slide, and have a
parameter to it that says left or right.
What else?
>> Okay, so
we can also turn our tuning dial.
>> Okay.
And here again,
we might want to have a parameter which
indicates the rotational angle or
something that indicates the information
that is being communicated from
the dial to the system, that's actually
going to change the vertical bar and
the actual tuning behavior of the radio.
>> Right.
Okay.
Another one is flipping our switch for
the AM or FM.
>> And, once again,
that's a left-right thing.
Okay?
>> I guess, is it not toggle, though?
It seems like since we just have two
options, kind of like toggling between,
do we need a-
>> Well, this particular clock radio
that I modeled, that's on the picture
there, is a slide switch left and right.
>> Okay.
And then I have pressing
the snooze button, but
I felt like it might need to be split,
because you could press the snooze
button while it's beeping, like kind
of the intended use case for that.
But you could also press
the snooze button when
It's just sitting there on accident or
something,
or you just fumble-
>> Okay, so
let's think about this a second.
As far as the user is concerned,
the event is pressing the button.
>> Okay.
What's in the user's head
is irrelevant here, okay?
At least as far as our initial
approximation of things.
Certainly, we want to consider the
possibility of what it means if the user
presses the snooze button when
the alarm is not going off.
And presumably, our resultant
state chart will describe for
us what behavior will happen.
This is one of the real reasons
we want to do this sort of thing,
is to come up with insights about,
well, I haven't thought about that yet.
And I need to take care of it.
We certainly don't want
the radio to go off
when it's not playing,
just because we hit the snooze button.
What else you have?
>> So, this is kind of
like three parts to this,
but when you press the wake button and
then press either the hour or minute
button, and then that's going to affect.
>> So is that one event or two?
>> I think the first event, there's
one event of pressing the wake button,
because that's going to
affect our different systems,
like displays is now going to
have to display our wake time.
So that's a separate event, and
then there's a conjoined event when you
press the wake button, and then you
press either the hour or minute buttons.
Now you're going to be
adjusting the display time,
so that's switching modes from your
display to wake, for instance.
And then you have this separate case for
actually changing the time.
>> Okay.
So, we want to be clear about this,
because this one of the different
ways that state chart modeling
forces us to think about things.
As far as the user events are concerned,
they're separate.
Okay, so, there's an event of
pressing that wake button and
releasing that wake button.
So another event here is release.
Pressing the wake button.
And then, there's a separate thing
going on, pressing the hour button.
The order in which those
happen is very important.
If you press the hour button first,
it's going to change the time of day.
>> Right.
>> Okay, if you press the wake button
first, then press the hour button,
it's going to change when you wake up.
So its important that the state chart
that we end up with reflects that
difference, because the user intends
them to be used differently.
The event is pressing the wake button,
the event is releasing the wake button.
Another event is pressing the hour
button and pressing the minute button.
And our machine, as we eventually refine
it to deal with all these contingencies,
had better behave in an expected way
as far as all of the precepts in all
of those possibilities,
all of those possible situations.